would you say that the evil comes from a
tiny minority of people
or does it permeate much larger parts of
the population
like if we look at sex trafficking
how many people
like is it 99.9 of the people are s
are um
longing to do good in the world but
or is there is it uh
or do we all have the capacity for evil
in certain kind of environment certain
kind of
uh governmental structures inspire a
large
percent of the population to do bad
things
i think humans are capable of anything
there's no exception
i don't think there's any saying to born
with a morality
i think in north korea you can say
initially that there's few guys in the
top
want the power and then doing this but
eventually made a society where people
don't even know what com compassion is
we don't know the concept of we don't
know that you need to feel bad for
another human being when they're
suffering
the fact that you know compassion is in
your knowledge that's why you do that
humans need to learn it's not anything
bad about human nature it's just saying
humans are capable of everything we are
the most adaptable species on the planet
that's why we
created the internet like talking this
way right
now other animals have done it because
we are so adaptable
that is a good thing and that's a bad
thing so in the adaptive situation
they all can be i mean during the
holocaust right those people
they could have been capable of good too
if they were exposed to different system
yeah and that's why when people
underestimate evil
that's what scares me evil is evil
it's a different thing it's a completely
different thing
and of course that i could really get
your idea we don't want to isolate 1.3
billion human beings in on earth by
chinese but the thing is we are talking
about this
regime not the people i love chinese
people i speak chinese i love
like all about the country but this
system
does promote evil well that's an
optimistic view actually because
we can fix systems yeah uh it's harder
to fix people
so if we fix systems then the people are
adaptable absolutely as you said
i mean that and then the question is uh
first of all you have to
talk about it just as you're doing
you're right now like this little flame
that burns bright and it's really
important for north korea
but just keep talking about it until
there's until hopefully leads to at the
highest levels of power
revolutionizing the systems in the world
and then
uh in china and in north korea do you
see
north korea being a potential instigator
of a nuclear war
they will not start a new korea war as
long as they can do whatever they want
right now
right north korea's army not designed to
fight the enemy they designed to prevent
their own people
the qut and the revolution with their
own citizens
that is 1.6 million north korea
with a tiny country the fourth largest
armies in the world
so this this country designed to fight
with their own citizens
and the army the fourth largest in the
world
is designed to basically fight its own
people oppress their own people that's
what north korean military is about
you